carrusel de las artes
[Música]
maría carolina piña
placer que estén en nuestra sintonía hoy
tengo el agrado de presentarles nuestro
programa carrusel de las artes desde las
instalaciones de la fundación castilla
de parís y hoy con una grandísima
invitada a la fotógrafa graciela
iturbide quien presenta aquí en parís
una gran retrospectiva de toda su obra
que reúne 50 años de trabajo fotográfico
gracias muchísimas gracias por estar en
nuestra compañía al contrario gracias a
ustedes bueno y es un honor para mí
tener la ca porque además hemos superado
muchísimos obstáculos que nos ha puesto
la crisis sanitaria pero una primera
pregunta que tengo para ustedes reunida
toda esta obra de 50 años de trabajo
fotográfico que es sentimiento tiene
usted y presentarlo aquí en parís
graciela bueno presentarlo aquí en parís
fascinada y realmente un agradecimiento
alexis fabry que fue el que reunió toda
mi obra nos conocemos hace mucho tiempo
él conoce bien un trabajo y él fue el
que organizó
digamos
la composición de toda esta exposición
la museografía estoy muy contenta y
ahora la exposición empieza con sus
primeros años de la fotografía de los
años 70 una fotografía en blanco y negro
y en esos primeros años usted se
interesó mucho en los pueblos indígenas
en su propio país en méxico y aquí en
esta exposición una pieza que se ha
vuelto icónica que es nuestra señora de
las iguanas de una fotografía en blanco
y negro hecha en oaxaca le hago la
pregunta y destacó esa obra porque de
alguna manera es
esa esa foto nos sigue sorprendiendo
todavía en el 2022 y creo que esa es su
manera de hacer fotografía siempre
buscando la sorpresa me equivoco no sí
en cuanto a lo que a mí me sorprenden si
te sorprende al público qué maravilla sí
pero yo trabajo con mi cámara y cuando
veo algo que me sorprende es cuando
disparó entonces generalmente voy por el
mundo por méxico los lugares buscando
algo que me sorprenda mi cara es como un
pretexto para conocer la cultura
tanto de mi país como del mundo y cada
vez que fotografía tan imparto a mis
libros para saber más sobre el país que
visite sobre lo que hice entonces una
manera de aprendizaje sobre la vida que
aprendió con esta fotografía que se ha
vuelto icónica incluso para los pueblos
indígenas de méxico es una mujer que
tiene como un tocado con cuatro o cinco
iguanas en la cabeza es una vendedora de
iguanas ella tiene las iguanas en la
cabeza porque las va a vender en el
mercado y todo lo carga en ellas en la
cabeza y bueno yo la vi le dije es pérez
espera de poder tomar la fotografía y mi
sorpresa es que se ha vuelto un icono
pero porque ella quiere porque yo no he
hecho nada está en las botellas de
mezcal
hay una gran escultura a la entrada de
cuchis tan de ella hay bordados en los
huipiles de ella hay cositas de barro
que la representan o sea que la sorpresa
para mí con esa foto fue que se volvió
un icono pero sin que yo hiciera nada
porque yo la tomé en cuchi tan le llaman
la mesa juchiteca entonces este pues yo
creo que ella quiere volar no sé porque
yo no he tenido nada que ver en esta
cosa pero si es una foto que se ha
vuelto un icono gracias para ustedes la
fotografía aparte de la sorpresa de
buscar lo que le sorprende usted misma
también le ha permitido descubrir su
propio país otros países aquí hay
fotografías que se han tomado en
madagascar in india es una manera para
ustedes la fotografía de descubrir otras
culturas pero también de descubrirse a
sí mismo claro claro descubrir otras
culturas al ver la diferencia entre mi
cultura y las otras culturas también me
estoy conociendo a mí misma estoy
aprendiendo de otros lugares pero al
mismo tiempo
reflexionando su manera de ser mi manera
de vivir o sea que siempre son
aprendizaje
[Música]
el interés de sus fotografías ha pasado
en 50 años del ser humano de esas
comunidades indígenas que les son
interesantes a ustedes la fotografía a
otras fotografías en otros periodos de
su vida y su trayectoria que tienen que
ver más con los objetos con los animales
de donde justamente usted sacó la
presencia humana como pasó de la
presencia humana a los objetos y porque
primero yo ya no vaya a las zonas
indígenas por el narcotráfico en méxico
es muy complicado pero yo creo que es
natural que yo pase de del ser humano de
los pájaros a las plantas porque todo
todo forma parte del mundo no todo lo
que está a nuestro alrededor del ser
humano es parte de nosotros entonces
poco a poco entrando el paisaje a los
pájaros a los objetos pero que
pertenecen al ser humano o sea que yo
siento que es lo mismo simplemente que
vas
bueno es una novela la siguiente novela
no será igual va a ser diferente
entonces tú vas captando en el mundo lo
que te sorprende lo que te interesa lo
nuevo que descubres dos días siento que
son las cosas naturales es
y ver a tu alrededor y tomar lo que está
a tu alrededor
i
[Música]
y algo que es natural también para los
mexicanos díganme si no es verdad es el
tema de la muerte así y eso también está
reflejado en esta exposición que
fotografías de esa serie que usted ha
hecho sobre la muerte quiso poner aquí
en parís bueno
como te dije el curador es el que él
quiso toda la que escogieron las
fotografías es alexis pero
nosotros en mexico como tú sabes jugamos
con la muerte y lloramos con la muerte y
le tenemos miedo a la muerte quizá por
eso jugamos con ella como yo voy muchas
fiestas en méxico todavía sigo yendo es
así la gente se viste de muerte se pone
máscaras de muerte se ponen como mujeres
embarazadas pero con la máscara de
muerte cuando la gente muere se le lleva
música cada año para festejarlos se les
lleva también
comida la música que le gustaba osea que
es como
algo muy natural sobre todo en el pueblo
de mexico es un día que tenemos al día
de muertos que es el día 2 de noviembre
donde celebramos donde regalamos
calaveras de azúcar donde está muy
presente todos los días en nuestra vida
la fantasía de la muerte y la verdad la
realidad y también incluso en los
matrimonios se puede recordar a la
muerte hay una fotografía de una novia
con cara de calavera pero en realidad es
un hombre claro ellos se disfrazan de
generalmente son los hombres que se
disfrazan las mujeres se quedan en su
casa haciendo la comida para la fiesta
pero si está la novia muerte yo le llamo
porque se puso embarazada incluso no con
su máscara si es algo muy natural en
méjico muy cotidiano
y no
alegre y muy triste a la vez y ahora
para esta exposición heliotropo 37 la
fundación castilla también le pidió
hacer
fotografías específicas para esta
exposición y del blanco y negro que
usted ha trabajado durante toda su vida
paso al color y a la piedra háblenos un
poco de ese trabajo en particular que es
bastante reciente y que fue hecho
especialmente para esta exposición bueno
a la orilla especialmente para esto
generalmente yo no tomo color algunas
veces lo he tomado entonces bueno fui
una mañana mafia tecali donde había
piedras estoy trabajando con piedras y
las tomé a color pero con mucho susto y
como no es tanto muy lenguaje pero las
tomé
y bueno no creas que me fascine todavía
[Música]
y ahora quisiera para interrogarlas
sobre el ambiente que tienen sus
fotografías porque cuando uno las ve hay
una calma que permite la contemplación
que invita a la contemplación y
justamente viendo esta serie me
preguntaba yo como graciela iturbide en
este mundo tan alocado tan lleno de
ritmo tan lleno de velocidad
usted sigue manteniendo esa calma para
fotografiar y buscando esa comprensión
bueno
me gusta el silencio me gusta la quietud
pero además siempre me albert en mi
maestro manuel álvarez dragón me decía
hay tiempo graciela no se apresure hay
tiempo y quizá eso más
mi personalidad es a una gente solitaria
de hacer las cosas con calma
hay tiempo me ayudó mucho a que las
cosas fueran más calmados qué bueno que
me lo dices porque me da gusto que te
sientas eso
en general si yo no soy creyente de nada
pero sí tengo
algo que ver con los escritores o con la
mística
me gusta mucho encontrar lugares
místicos
tranquilos me encanta
para ustedes la fotografía puede
reflejar la verdad la realidad o la
fotografía es otra realidad
cuando yo hago fotografía yo interpreto
lo que veo no es la realidad es lo que
yo vi si es la realidad pero vista a los
ojos de gracia distribuida el público
cuando vea mis fotografías va a
interpretar lo que yo ya interprete pero
a su manera ellos van a tener un
concepto totalmente diferente quizás de
cuando yo vi ese objeto o ese paisaje o
esa persona y que yo lo interpreté a mi
manera
entonces la fotografía para mí la
fotografía no es la realidad es una
partecita de la realidad que dice el
color pero pero yo no intento en
fotografía dar la realidad
simplemente intento en todo caso
expresar si el público fotos lo que yo
sentí creo que no es verdad la
fotografía ya para terminar esta
entrevista esta plática graciela si yo
le pidiera en estas doscientas más de
200 fotografías que se presentan si
usted tuviera una preferida cuál sería
nada y es muy difícil porque nunca tengo
preferidas y cuando tengo una foto
preferida es cuando acabo de hacer un
trabajo y por ejemplo ahora que las
islas canarias que estoy revelando toda
mi obra digo ay qué maravilla pero ya se
pasa el tiempo y ya se fue la maravilla
hasta que vuelvo a fotografiar así
preferidas no todas son parte de mi vida
todas las quiero pero nada más seguir
haciendo fotografías que
seguiré madera todo el tiempo porque es
mi terapia de vida sí gracias pues
muchísimas gracias por haber compartido
con nosotros este momento en el seno de
su muestra heliotropo 37 aquí en la
fundación castilla muchísimas gracias
por habernos dado el regalo de su
presencia el linda muchísimas gracias
[Música]